fish stocks in the Baltic Sea will be on
the table of EU ministers responsible
for fisheries when they meet in
Luxembourg on april 20 they will discuss
a multi annual plan for cod herring and
Sprott to make sure that the fish stocks
in the Baltic are exploited in a
sustainable way agriculture ministers
will be briefed by the European
Commission on the mandatory country of
origin indication for food products such
as milk dairy certain types of meat and
unprocessed food this has gained
importance in the beginning of 2013 when
fraudulent use of horse meat was
detected in some processed food the
European Commission will also present a
model guarantee instrument for
agriculture prepared in cooperation with
the european investment bank this
instrument will help ease access to
finance for farmers and unlock
much-needed investment in rural areas
finally ministers will determine the e
use position at the United Nations forum
on forests taking place in May the forum
intends to strengthen long-term
international political commitments in
favor of sustainable forestry a key
element in the fight against climate
change